[Music]
have you ever seen a dog cinematographer
before well I certainly have it so I
wanted to OB be the world's very first
cinematographer let's see if we can
actually make that happen real quick I
wanna introduce a game for you go oh
yeah this is a dangerous game however is
a game called defender Amazon where you
go with your hands on and you look at
your last six months of purchases and
you have to defend to everyone else why
you purchase all you guys are so scared
everything wanna miss like the leave be
cool yeah we can do it I'd advise me on
a I'm coming three years you bought oh
my god you nerd
the we will quit smart plug an fpv
camera a bunch of small batteries to
miss for your roof yeah and a nerf arrow
how was football like the old like flies
uncle is 12 we have a birthday coming up
okay it's a bit when OB is running
around and mentioned the cam can be
shaped in the lots and when a camera is
bigger and heavier it's more weight and
mink around and pull a rig around I want
this to be as light as possible so it
can be sturdy and not get self thrown
around too much okay Toby even likes
having this crap table yeah I have to do
some safety pinning and stuff sit good
boy yeah good boy
the thing should never shoot with
animals or children and yet here we were
are shooting with Obion rim we did a
Rayman video back in the day and we need
as a kid to be like a little like wizard
to make a blade II like takes a long
time putting the beard on making to look
good it put a little a lot of glue and
like my hair is on kinda visually the
glue kind of dries and gets all hichy
the kid is literally running around the
parking lot
screaming ahh like wanting to pull this
beard off you constantly reaching
reaching up so I like pull it off enough
like no no no leave it on
even Jesus
yeah I just think that officer yeah he's
all happy and keeps running around just
in absolute terror Sam and I are they're
like oh my god you get a shot with kids
and like the next 20 minutes
oddly enough the once we had the female
actress in her Barbra costume she became
the kids best friend like the kid was
like in touch with her immediately and
would do anything she said she told me
get the beard back on ditch don't go
stamens mark she did like all right and
do your actions it means like perfectly
behaved so there you have it get the
secrets you having kids on set it's just
to have like a female cartoon characters
running around and then they'll pay
attention
that video is unlisted on our channel
good you can try to find it by going to
our old videos and listen for a link
because it's still accessible it's not
very easy to find
challenge accepted good luck guys we're
gonna go with a human chest mount we're
going to resize it for a dollar
let's go seeing this bits over I mean it
kind of really good feel what's that
you're like GoPro arable gimbal he goes
various filter here a well reviewed 64
gig SD card 8 port USB 3 hub a USB
converter for audio this looks like 56
liners those are active Chargers are Wow
you use the I can shrug North dressed
yet there's no it's a fine if have on
strengthen what is yeah I gotta be gone
do that you guys do the pumpkin or yes
here we go HP ink cartridges or gain
plant-based proteins shower hook hanger
a shower curtain a Bluetooth smart some
smart scale I feel like you also
returned a shower Assessor every did
with that every
your bathroom because this is awesome
and over here you go it's also very
deserting individual because there are I
should note return the things in here
they definitely try things that would be
like that one of squatty potties oh holy
help is very important fun facts ready
yeah we don't have a squatty potty here
and I'm used to it I just can't I think
it would be just gross like no I need to
elevate that the other day they took one
of the apple tree should not sell out to
anybody you clearly use Amazon when
you're taking dumps at home in your
bathroom and you look around you're like
what do we do you give you hangers this
is the most adult out of all them
you know men would be proud okay she's a
mini poodle and pools have this thing
where they only really like other poodle
other dog things don't really care too
much about but if it's poodle all in it
makes their day and people fools really
connect with people because he's racist
this is a wearable gimbal not sit right
here and I'll keep it stabilized and now
it's on the GoPro stuff you can put this
on od
[Music]
like what is it it's hearing all
anybody's okay you have a pretty decent
amount of time where could we do a
little a little tight
Oh
[Music]
we had this thing where it's like I
could put the leash on him but if I just
put the leash on the ground he'll think
he's like anchored to the ground so I
think it's something similar that it's a
human like try leaving if the leashes
their neck seems like I'm stuck I think
that was kind of what was happening here
he kind of studies stuff and we're
absolutely positive it wasn't a battery
thing yes did you try any battery you
can see it try to turn on because the
gimm will hit the ground really hard it
doesn't work anymore it's broken
fortunately our friends over at Zion I
think it's another one we just got to
wait for it to get here oh they're here
well Felix I hear you punk
they're going to be easier to get like
they have a super supportive Arkana
stuff yes that have like that's been a
fully fabric so Laura I know Nico that
you're really is banality Natalie tells
you this icon - oh we got sister place
the spin for the go throwing is done oh
boy not everyone that dog in these
pictures looks like what's up it's going
I ready to clown a harness that hit the
GoPro do you want on a harness
okay good boy oh we will whistling hands
through
this is the updated version of the same
gimbal that we had before lighter weight
because of that it should fit on OB
easier maybe it won't bother him as much
as this like backward be righter smooth
and not the writer end this is the
writer smooth in this is smooth moon the
smoothest end
hey Nick can you think of any words that
start with him and I not that doesn't
have an I in it and I any words that
start with M and I
it was great baby wouldn't that get the
fit off of me little Milken the kept hid
in his front legs whenever you try to
walk why was it underneath
a human you humiliate me what come back
there go throw it so far he just doesn't
like move with the gimbal on so let's go
try to find something more comfortable
you treat like come on
what what so so so he doesn't
particularly like run flower in the best
what if he flew instead
[Applause]
[Music]